sur ces images satellites un immense
qu'on voit militaire russe plusieurs
dizaines de véhicules déployés sur 60 km
au nord-ouest de Kiev la capitale
ukrainienne toujours bombardée un dépôt
pétrolier est ici pour cible hier à
carquif 2e ville de l'Ukraine les
bombardements russes sont intenses
deux silhouettes que l'on distingue en
haut à droite tente de fuir l'une d'elle
est à terre ces images de
vidéosurveillance témoignent de la
puissance du déluge de feu
sur ces vidéos diffusées par les
autorités locales un centre commercial
est pris pour cible des immeubles des
quartiers résidentiels frappés en pleine
journée
ici les victimes au sol sont civiles
l'attaque a fait au moins 11 morts
le maire de la ville prend la parole
depuis un abri selon lui quatre
personnes auraient quitté les lieux dans
la journée pour aller chercher de l'eau
elles ont été tuées car kiff a changé de
visage des bâtiments sont éventrés un
certain endroit de la ville ces obus
restaient plantés dans le sol un peu
partout dans le pays les combats se
poursuivent 6e jour de guerre en Ukraine
sixième jour d'angoisse pour les
populations civiles